january known as divorce month with the
holidays you know they're now behind us
local experts say this is a time when a
lot of married couples consider calling
it quits hector mejia reporting live
this morning hector i know you talked to
a local attorney
tell us about the trends he's seen
really interesting stuff good morning
heather well the attorney says he's
noticed between 30 and 40 percent more
phone calls
individuals asking questions about the
whole divorce process so we talked with
the law office of romeo perez over by
flamingo and spencer and he tells us
january turned out to be a busy month
with divorce consultations perez
believes many wait for the holidays to
be over or for their income tax return
to use that money to hire a divorce
attorney and from his perspective the
pandemic is another factor that's pushed
more couples to consider a breakup i
asked him about the trends other trends
he's seeing here in las vegas
what we're seeing a lot of now is kind
of what we saw in the late 90s which is
people weren't necessarily fighting over
the kids they were fighting over the
house
we've got the house values that have
skyrocketed in the last two years
and people are fighting over the equity
for couples that are on the fence perez
first recommends seeking marriage
counseling especially when children are
involved he says family law is all about
the best interest of the children and we
also talked with an expert over at unlv
she talks about an increase in domestic
violence who want to hear what she has
to say about that she will also go over
the signs to recognize that's still
ahead in the next half hour reporting
live hector mejia live local now